tesla is no doubt years ahead of the
competition
when it comes to electric and autonomous
car markets
this is thanks to not only tesla's fast
pace but more importantly decades of
negligence from basically all of the
legacy car makers
despite this gaping lead most of the
executives at companies like toyota and
general motors like to play it off with
the situation
is not that bad this is the case with
most executives except one
which is a former ceo of volkswagen
herbert dice
so here's a herbert admiration for tesla
as well as his persistence for change
quickly got amounted from his position
as ceo
starting off herbert dice has been a fan
of tesla and elon musk for years
in fact herbert even invited elon musk
last year to test drive volkswagen's new
id3 electric vehicle
you see herbert was well aware of the
fact that electric and autonomous
vehicles were the future
and that wolveswagon was not spending
nearly enough effort in trying to catch
up
now herbert was the ceo of volkswagen
but it's not like he founded volkswagen
and has a majority share in the company
he was actually working at bmw till 2015
and he didn't become ceo of the
volkswagen group till 2018
thus within the executive leaders of
volkswagen herbert was still relatively
new
and he didn't have too much power by
himself he needed the majority of the
other executives as well as the board
members to rally behind any major
decision he wanted to make
there were a few other executives like
thomas ulbrick who also shared herbert's
vision of going fully electric
and autonomous as soon as possible but
unfortunately
it doesn't seem like the majority of
executives were quite as passionate or
persistent and radically changing the
future of the company
as a result herbert and thomas would go
out and start making quite strong
statements about tesla's lead
maybe this was a planned effort in which
they tried to gain investor support for
a radical eevee shift within volkswagen
or maybe they were just frustrated with
volkswagen's leadership
and simply vented their concerns either
way though
beginning in 2020 the two would make
statements that would attract the
attention of the entire automotive
industry
herbert would start relatively tame with
one of his first remarks coming up in
volkswagen's power day event in march of
2020.
during the event herbert would begin the
show by asserting quote
let me begin with the obvious emobility
has won the race
when he refers to emobility basically
everyone knows that he's referring to
tesla
thus many news organizations would
subsequently claim that this
is as close as you're going to get when
it comes to a ceo admitting a
competitor's lead
but herbert was just getting started and
it wouldn't be long until he started to
name drop tesla
meanwhile thomas albrecht was already
name-dropping tesla
in an interview around the same time
thomas would state quote
united states electric car manufacturer
tesla has a tenure start on rivals when
it comes to building electric cars
and software he would go on to clarify
that wolf's wagon is very quick in
catching up
but i'd say the damage was already done
anyways
moving forward herbert would expand his
praise from just tesla's ev
lead to their thomas vehicle lead as
well near the end of april 2020
herbert would express quote what worries
me most is the capabilities in the
assistant systems
500 000 teslas function as a neural
network that continuously collects data
and provides a customer new driving
experience
every 14 days with improved properties
now
that's a big statement in itself but he
would instantly put the nail in the
coffin as he stated quote
no other automobile manufacturer can do
that today
honestly i don't know if he could have
been any more blunt about the matter
herbert and thomas would go on to make
several statements throughout the first
half of 2020
and this would not only bolster the
sentiment for tesla but
it would simultaneously shatter investor
confidence in legacy automakers
maybe that was a plan all along and
maybe
herbert was looking to take advantage of
this distressed situation to change the
direction of volkswagen
we'll never know for sure but his next
course of action does suggest
that this was the case herbert would
turn around and push for volkswagen to
make a massive investment
and when i say massive i mean gigantic
herbert wanted volkswagen to invest a
whopping 84 billion euros into ev
and av development 34 billion euros
would go towards developing
and building electric and autonomous
vehicles and
the other 50 billion would go towards
developing battery technology
now let's just keep in mind that 84
billion euros or about 100 billion
dollars
is enough money to buy the entire
company of general motors and have 14
billion dollars to spare
so herbert basically wanted volkswagen
to go all in on evs
and avs i don't think you'll be
surprised to hear that the other
executives weren't so thrilled to hear
about this plan
first of all this was during the start
of the pandemic and wolves back in stock
was down up to 50 percent compared to
january of 2020.
considering that each executive likely
owns tens of millions of dollars worth
of volkswagen stock
they weren't having the best of days and
the last thing they wanted to do was
yolo on the eevee market
the stock drop wasn't even the biggest
deal though stock prices fluctuate up
and down
however if you have a strong
fundamentally growing company
the stock price is only heading up over
the long term the real problem was that
the fundamental business of volkswagen
was taking a significant hit due to the
pandemic
before the pandemic volkswagen was
consistently now profiting about three
to four billion dollars per quarter
in the first quarter of 2020 this would
plummet 90 to 447 million dollars
and during the second quarter of 2020
volkswagen would actually lose
1.7 billion dollars aside from major
financial problems
volkswagen was also facing significant
production issues with a couple of their
best-selling models
also volkswagen was forced to stop sales
of their new golf model
as it had notable software issues from
the perspective
of the other leaders it seemed like
herbert was busy trying to solve
problems five to ten years in the future
instead of tending to these immediate
issues so when herbert proposed a 84
billion euro investment to the other
executives and the board
i suspect they thought he was delirious
to make things even worse
the sourcing of the funding didn't make
many board members very happy either
84 billion euros is a massive investment
even for a company as large as
volkswagen
and thus to make such an investment
possible volkswagen will need to cut
back greatly on their current gas
related endeavors
herbert proposed cutting back on r d
investments and fixed costs relating to
ice vehicles
the rest of the executive team wasn't
actually that opposed to this idea
i mean the company was literally losing
hundreds of millions of dollars
so cutting back costs made a lot of
sense whether these cost savings would
actually be used to develop eb
technology like herbert suggested
was a discussion for another day
conversely
several members on the company board
weren't so fond of the idea
you see 9 out of the 19 board members
were labor leaders
meaning that it was their job to look
out for the jobs of the average factory
worker
at volkswagen and herbert's cost cutting
measures would of course mean that
thousands
if not tens of thousands of employees
would be laid off for obvious reasons
the labor leaders didn't like this and
this put herbert in a position where he
had beef with nearly all of the other
executives and board members for various
reasons
and just when you think that things
can't get any worse they would
some confidential volkswagen information
would be linked to the media
and herbert would put out a statement
that seemed to accuse the other leaders
of volkswagen for the leak
this allegation pushed the board over
the edge and soon enough
there would be discussions amongst these
other leaders about whether they should
replace herbert
many leaders actually wanted herbert
completely out of the company
but herbert would apologize for his
recent brash behavior and the leaders
would decide to show him a bit of mercy
instead of kicking him completely out of
the company on june 8th 2020
they would decide to trip away his role
as wolves wagon ceo
he would still remain the ceo of the
overall volkswagen group
now that sounds like a super cool
position but really the only reason the
board let him keep this position
is because the position is basically
just fluff according to volkswagen
herbert will focus on overall strategy
for the group
but we all know this is just fluff the
ceos
and the executive teams of each of
volkswagen's individual companies are
the ones that really play a hands-on
role in the group's overall future
anyways ralph bradstatter the previous
ceo of volkswagen
replaced herbert as ceo and that's how
it's been
ever since as for herbert he's just been
even more savage
after the event for instance after tesla
posted their queue to earnings which
were unexpectedly positive
herbert would go out of his way to state
quote elon musk delivers results that
many have deemed impossible
he went on to reveal that tesla's
results support his viewer that in five
to ten years
the world's most valuable company will
be a mobility company that can be called
tesla
apple or volkswagen in the end
volkswagen has recovered from their
pandemic low
and they are taking their first steps
into the eevee industry
so it's not like volkswagen is going to
go bankrupt or anything like that
in fact it's likely that volkswagen will
remain a large automobile manufacturer
for decades to come
however herbert really wanted to
challenge tesla in the electric and
autonomous vehicle space
and push volkswagen to be the biggest
company in the entire world
without undergoing a radical change like
herbert proposed though this destiny
remains unlikely
and it's quite a shame that the
bureaucratic nature and corporate
politics of volkswagen
prevented herbert from taking volkswagen
in this direction
who knows though dice hasn't left the
volkswagen group just yet
and maybe he still has something up his
sleeve
what do you guys think about herbert
dice being ousted comment that down
below
also drop a like if you guys thought
this video explained the situation well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one